brian
is in california hey brian welcome to
the dave ramsey show
all right enjoy your show thank you and
uh the good advice you give
and when you follow it then you have a
question like
i have um i'm sort of looking for a
philosophical discussion
do you give money to your adult children
uh now when they're in their 30s they
or you know do you hold off and provide
it as part of your estate when
when you're gone what do you think well
there's
uh two or three elements of that that i
look at
um and that i've looked at with my own
uh ramsey kids uh
they're all adults at this point um
number one element is are they being
responsible
are they misbehaving if they're
misbehaving and i give them money all
i'm gonna do is magnify their
misbehavior whatever the misbehavior is
i mean if they're doing drugs or they're
just won't work much or
they're irresponsible or they're
impulsive but if they're doing a good
job
you know they're being reasonable people
they're mature they're saving money
they're giving money
they have a plan they're working
together with their spouse they're not
lying to each other about purchases
and you know that kind of stuff they've
got a good healthy
money situation then you'll magnify the
healthy situation when you give
them money and so uh you're not there
you're not enabling
bad behavior uh at that point the second
variable is of course the size of your
estate if your estate is in excess of 20
million you have gotten into serious
federal estate tax problems and uh
i don't know how big your estate is but
if you're there uh
you've got you're much better off to
offload some of that systematically
to keep the government's hands off of it
if it is in the estate
but let's say you've got five or ten
million dollars you're more than okay
do you want to give up each one of them
a hundred grand pay off their house or
something
yeah if they're responsible i would do
that
but i don't want to magnify because
whatever you give them money
anytime there's more money involved than
there was it magnifies
what was already there in all of our
lives
if they got a temper they'll have a
bigger temper when you've got more money
and so uh we talk about that in legacy
journey a lot
is in that sense but
brian how many kids do you have
uh we have two boy and a girl and a
woman i guess at this point they're both
working responsible people um you know
in california
i wish you could pay off a mortgage with
a hundred grand uh
dave but uh well i'm just saying his
example i don't care if it's 300 grand
how much money have you got
um we're between 10 and 15.
good for you awesome yeah i mean there's
no reason to not offload some of that to
them
if you can do it in a way that's tax
efficient um
and you've got it you need to be with a
good tax advisor
as a part of your estate plan you can
use the unified estate tax credit up to
a point
uh and you know keep from having gift
tax on it and that kind of thing
but yeah i mean if it if you got 15
million and you give each of them a
million and it pays off their house
california well it's still okay it is
and dave you have talked and i remember
years ago i've been with you almost 15
years now but you were talking about
being very intentional
and having conversations with your kids
helping
them to be able to prepare them to be
able to handle
whatever is left to them and i took note
of that and i've passed that on to other
people
and uh they're taking it to heart of
it's an intentional meeting
where you've got to help people get
ready to handle wealth yeah we've
we've trained them uh it sounds like his
are already out of the house and grown
so you know i've had a friend in your
situation uh brian that did
you know offload a couple million bucks
to each kid or a million bucks to each
kid that kind of a thing
uh tax efficiently with good advice uh
and but he put he put some strings on it
he said you know you need to sign a
letter that says you're never gonna
borrow money again
i wanna break the uh habit i wanna break
the chain on my family tree right here
that's this
and uh he said i want that's what i want
for it i want you to
i don't want you to go further in debt
because i gave you this that's right